reportage pour vous faire un sourire
maintenant et ça c'est bel et bien
déroulé aujourd'hui des recherches pour
retrouver dans les environs de saint
lazare à l'ouest de montréal
un kangourou alors à louise des peuples
et un bébé kangourou en plus à nourrice
despatie nous donne la suite au centre
murmure d'animaux il y a des chevaux
deux dromadaires un zèbre et il y avait
un kangourou jusqu'à hier soir
mirka une petite femelle de 12 mois est
sorti de son enclos profitant d'une
porte mal fermée en espérant qu'il soit
quand même proche
j'imagine qu'elle est encore dans la
région issus de la bonne nouvelle c'est
que mirka répond à son nom et n'a pas
peur des humains
en revanche elle peut se déplacer très
vite et loin c'est sans compter les
coyotes qu'elle pourrait croiser moi je
suis à challes depuis 10h30 ce matin des
dizaines de cavaliers ont sillonné les
sentiers et la campagne environnante
il y a beaucoup de fermes équestres aux
alentours on peut rentrer dans le bois
facilement couvraient plus de distance
le zou papa n'a qu en ontario a prêté le
petit marsupial à luc lefebvre
il y a trois mois il voulait voir
comment mirka peut participer au projet
de zoothérapie qu'il démarre à l'automne
un animal qui est extrêmement doux c'est
un animal qui était en mesure de pouvoir
aider les jeunes
donc ça fait plusieurs mois qu'elle est
en entraînement amoureux des chevaux et
des animaux luc lefebvre travaille
depuis des années à mettre sur pied son
projet qui serait incomplet sans un
kangourou un souvenir d'enfance
l'histoire finit aussi bien qu'un
épisode de skippy la cavale de mirka
vient tout juste de se terminer
elle aura été au large à peine 24 heures
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
saint lazare